un public de la semaine françoise sagan
car le sagan nouveau est arrivé
il a pour titre avec mon meilleur
souvenir et aurait pu s'appeler trente
ans après puisqu'aussi bien bonjour
tristesse c'est 1954 depuis il ya eu 15
vraiment le jeu la vitesse et quelques
figures comme celles de billie holiday
tiny si williams ou dolce noureev et
jean paul sartre mais françoise est
resté sagan pour sagan lorsque j'ai
annoncé à fr3 que j'avais vous
interviewez on m'a dit mais c'est pas
possible on ne peut pas interviewer qui
n'auraient difficile elle est timide ne
pas se livrer ça vous gêne un peu cette
image de main des princes non je ne
saisis pas très bavarde c'est vrai mais
pourra prendre la question au dialogue
et aux dépens des questions c'est
toujours pareil on ne l'a pas fait
facilement devant une caméra aurait
complètement facilement à des questions
devant une caméra mais des données comme
ça alors question bateau vous êtes
timide
tout au plus tôt et comment est-ce qu'on
peut être timide lorsqu'on s'appelle
sagan qui a mille concède encore aperçu
avec la sortie de ce livre
les gens se sont dit prêtes ou mais
sagan non seulement ça existe sakho bien
existé ça fait 30 ans que mongeau
pestait 6 mai 1954
on y arrive on est en mai 1984 alors
comment être dit mid vous allez bien
qu'est-ce que vous présentez votre le
poids le fait que ma santé me permis de
vivre trente ans de plus pour ça ne
m'empêche pas les petits league
la constitution est timide vont nous
faire quelquefois vous avez de bonnes
côté du rhin à 80 privé bon je veux
savoir quand est-ce que ça je ne sais
pas on la rosa peut-être poser cette
question là j'en suis pas convaincu
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'un jour vous
vous êtes mis devant une machine à
écrire parce que ça c'est important la
machine à écrire la saga pourrait écrire
un roman c'était quoi qu'est-ce que oui
c'est un livre qui j'étais mais j'étais
la seule bonne je tiens à propos des tic
j'ai passé mes des bâches ou en octobre
leur patrie brillamment et j'ai fait et
prophétique pour faire une licence de
lettres histoire
et puis la sorbonne il faut être
courageux pour le travail et la tendance
à traîner un peu dans les cafés autour
de leurs gonds mon cas dans ma part en
tout cas et j'ai écrit un roman sur un
petit cahier dans les cafés autour de la
sorbonne
et puis voilà puis c'est pas jay chou et
pathétique j'ai passé mon été à paris
j'ai tapé la machine ces petits romans
et voilà petit roman et ça recommence je
prends des tables car même d'ailleurs
une dimension bon quand vous l'avez a
mené on connaît un peu l'histoire de
besoin de premiers romans dont on devra
le titre tout à l'heure si jamais
quelqu'un l'avait oublié c'était
pourquoi c'était un
pour vous prouver quelque chose c'était
quoi non c'était le temps long depuis
que je lisais j'avais envie d'écrire
alors disons ses ennemis alors j'ai
commencé à écrire celui convenu fini que
des étapes et quand il a eu un air un
peu présentables on ne sait jamais
allongé envahi à deux éditeurs alors est
comment est ce que vous expliquez trente
ans après le succès c'est une question
qu'on a posé 100 fois j'ai sur les
incapables directement si vous lisiez
ont donc de nouveau lisier holliger créé
pour vous prouver peut-être soldats vous
même que vous pouviez aussi créé des
remous lisier quoi qu'est ce qui te
laisserai la main puisqu'ils ont
d'ailleurs tous deux au top et il
explique la présence qu'innover gigue
camus et sartre elle est rouge sélestat
d'année les bacs et tout ce qu'on peut
découvrir la littérature à 14,15 en
effet beaucoup de papas ce serait
beaucoup d'eux s'était beaucoup de
sujets d'inspiration en tout cas vers
vous l'avez prix commencent ce succès je
n'aime pas sûrs y com com comme tout le
monde j'ai été ahuri par le
oui de sa vie et puis un moment ça va
pas vers un petit peu excessif comme
boeing et lorsqu'il fit partie j'ai filé
vers une plage vous avez remarqué qu
actuellement il ya une grande mode c'est
dire bonjour
lorsque un verre ça va trois verres
bonjour les dégâts
bonjour l'émission sera en fait vous
avez inventé tout ça avec bonjour
tristesse
bonjour sa fait ça fait 30 ans que l'on
oublie que ce que mon fils à ses sorties
bonjour bonjour les dégâts c'est assez
récent je crois c'est une expression qui
revient à la mode depuis ne sais pas je
pas responsables bonjour les dégâts
bonjour nous ne serons pas au jeu
permettrait de penser que j'ai passé là
ça va sourire parce que c'était pas
facile le second tristesse et un titre à
mascate est obligé d'emprunter aguilar
on essaie d'assurer aux sacres de tours
hamilton
vous n'avez pas le sentiment quand même
connaître votre talent et ça on va en
parler
vous avez été fabriqués au nom se sent
jamais fabriqué on est peut-être nantis
sans tabou ni sp 2000 que vous vous êtes
auto de loi et l'esprit de tous les
scandales à l'époque où deux espèces ou
des neiges qui était fait parler à la
presse mais finalement je me sens pas
fabriquer très très loin des glycines
temps vous n'avez pas été fabriqués mais
ce que je n'ai pas le sentiment quand
même qu'on a ici de ceuta despatie
abandon technique on appellera ça
maintenant médiatique mais quand quand
vous regardez quand vous regardez ce que
vous avez fait depuis 30 ans une trente
ans c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui ne viennent pas
printemps oui non si pittoresque et 1,91
vous relisez non comment ça non je ne
lis pas je m'épanouis vrai dire j'ai
parisien les miens que je connais par
terre vous n'avez pas lu vos tristesse
depuis qu enfin vous n'avez pas cette
curiosité de vous relire non une fois je
suis tombé sur un livre de moi dans un
avion et l'accès à lire j'avais des dans
un mois dans un an nous rappelle 3 est
troisième et dernier but à l'autre et
c'est comment t'es tu penses à gandhi
sagan sait de quoi on a pris pas mal
ils sont punis pas mal vous auriez été
pigiste de madère littéraire nouvelle
époque où il est française vous arrivez
faire un bouquin
l'article 10 ans a atteint les liens qui
serait donné quoi grosso modo souhaitait
que je n'ai pas posté pas mal et il y
avait un peu trop de personnages est
passé de pages lorsqu'un petites
embrouilles
mais c'était pas mal on vous a beaucoup
reproché de ne pas être prolixe au
niveau de la pagination
oui sauf l'avant-dernier mon amante
années 1600 pages c'est un désir de quoi
de resserrer le propos le récit niveau
du volume se passent un à deux égards un
volume aux 208 7 à 3 5 t il en avait nos
publics ou aux proches et on vous a
reproché aussi incertaines et d'une
facilité laisser aller dans le style on
sait bien sûr toujours sujet verbe
complément des reproches vous vous
défendez une défense il te faut des
reproches comme ça que mes petites
filles avec les grands clubs sévère
pourrait faire mieux a pas tenu sa copie
aurifère plus nourris de faire plus
pauvres la pasteurisation ce qui est des
proches d'enfants
vous êtes toujours à l'enfance que de ça
c'est toujours été un petit peu comme un
enfant internet arabe en général pendant
encore longtemps qu'on vienne dire on le
sait pas à vivre à lire
à lire du même auteur dans le dernier ce
qui va sortir de la marque à 16 romans
et puis des limites et théâtre de trois
aucun don dont vous dites que tu
d'allemands se lever sur le coup ça vous
paraît très utile lors on peut
difficilement se renier et demain
peut-être un ou deux que ce soit mieux
que les autres ça m'a dit maman mais
qu'on perde et faisant que les autres
mais vraiment inutile je crois pas ou de
l'école j'aimais bien là le mieux gardé
de la sasp après c'est parce que mes
enfants si la jsk les rappeurs et puis
la femme fardée ce témoin le groupe
arabe
et puis accepter les bleus à l'âme chez
nous alors donc les 5 ans du début les
sags en un scandale
et là on peut sourire parce que l'on
jour triste est un scandale oui avec ce
qui peut se lire recevoir 195 vous prête
ses traits d'esprit n'est pas celle
qu'elle est immense et c'est plus que la
bullet with a nice comme on n'est pas si
je vais j'y ai bien quand même oser des
jeunes car ça te sers aggravation 8
quand vous avez construit très bien très
agréable
aujourd'hui je donc joué le jeu pour le
jeu de j avais un métier technique qui
me paquin passionnés qui nous passionne
toujours puis j'avais en plus des moyens
de mener la vie la vie qui me plaisait
la vie rêvée
hélas non l'autre à fait délicieuse
alors je suis
portier d'hôtel vous arrivez à minuit
je voudrais rappeler ni fischer pour ça
c'est ma profession table et le 5 ans
chez gallimard
c'est extraordinaire ça excuse des bases
et et s'est passé que j'étais d'un autre
à maison d'édition avant et que là je
suis arrivé chez gallimard
une consécration pour vous voici une
étude et c'est considéré comme une
maison d'édition de paris il ya sûrement
des raisons qui ne serait ce que par les
auteurs appartenant et non plus ne
savait chez casino avec vos potes
content pour dire qu'il sort d'une demi
heure ils ont réparé puisque je pense
qu'ils ont les meilleurs je pense qu'ils
sont la meilleure maison d'édition ils
ont évidemment les meilleurs internet
c'est vrai qu'il ya un terreau du monde
actuellement chez elle et j'y suis
arrivé après quelques péripéties qui
arrive et ça vous flatte aco verte et
blanche avec le filet au jeu noir je
serai un traître un très joli et
techniquement oui mais pas répondu c'est
flatteur mais sinon ça va barder d'avoir
des compagnons d'écurie aussi
prestigieux c'est quoi ce sont des
mémoires non non on dirait que c'est du
cinquante moi je peux pas dire ça moi je
le dis abondamment ici nous a volés
inventé quoi vous avez choisi des choses
vous avez choisi quoi j'aime logo n'est
pas honnête je me raconte pas les deux
champs qui me plaisait vous qui m'avez
plus j'admirais et puis pas aussi des
choses qui m'amusent et qu'une plaisir
dans la vie c'est à dire des gens comme
je vais rencontrer qu'il m'avait fasciné
et puis aussi des choses qui dans la vie
m'avait toujours plus continuer à créer
alors dans ce mythe sagan sa maman en 3d
par ce comportement de presse où il a eu
de grands patrons de presse rapportant
lazareff nous a beaucoup aidés oui à le
jeu il ya de certains nouveaux certains
de vos prédécesseurs qui ont bien parlé
de jeu 11 d'or il oblige dostoïevski oui
et alors le jeu ça représente exactement
en quoi c'est un pari c'est que la
chance c'est un flirt avec la chance au
nez la chance dating pas comme ça mais
de celui de monolithes et définir un
joueur c'est absolument impossible ou
deux joueurs et l'on comprend des
masques c'est que le jeu et on aime ça
on n'est pas joueur et on a horreur de
ça passe et commettre aucun être
intelligent rancunier lettres joueurs
c'est notre faveur c'est une chose qu'on
dit on il n'est qu'on a comme peuple
sont pas nîmes et reporteront peut-être
le maîtriser mais qu'on ne peut pas
acquérir une je crois pas au mondial
c'est une drogue ça le bonheur où il
tombera ce qu'on veut c'est une drogue
snabe tissant goussainville couverture
comment explique t elle en biologie
n'est qu'une nation que logique retraite
certes assez sérieuse pourrait prendre
bon oui de plus en plus n'ont pas plus
en plus je joue quand je suis pas de
près d'un casino ce que j'ai dit en
général et voilà et pour que vous ne
jouez caucase il osait ce que c'est par
l'environnement du casino qui vous
fascine puisque le couple paraît même du
jeu
e on joue pour des faits la chance pour
votre question son équilibre financier
sa vie des choses dans des stades madame
sa mère de vivre si je vais pas jouer
des dg pas jouer d'argent avec dix amis
à moi ce serait qu'il soit ce qui serait
pas de gras ni pour eux ni pour moi et
j'ai plus en plus de contrôles des gens
inconnus ce qui est extrêmement
dangereux par conséquent le joue au
casino contre la chance plusieurs ont
joué au casino pour rétablir avec les
financiers donc n'ont pas encore établi
pour établir un peu d'équilibré en tout
cas pour le provoquer et que vous jouez
vous venez de l'argent ce bateau les
armes et l'argent qu'est-ce que vous
croyez
et quand vous en perdez c'est quoi une
fois où ça n'arrange pas du tout vous
pouvez imaginer évaluer combien dans
votre existence et je ne compte pas je
vous ai raconté combien vous avez gagné
d'argent qu'on vient vous en avez perdu
non je peux vous dire précisément disons
que j'ai que j'ai beaucoup j'ai plutôt
gagné comment ça se passe pourquoi
est-ce qu'on gagne c'est le pit c'est
quoi annoncer la fin ça mon
questionnement et sa calandre ou perd
tout le temps il faut s'arrêter il pas
le ganil fois ci il paraît qu'il ya des
méthodes de jeu les bernois gaz c'est
quoi la chance pour qui il y avait
tellement jouer qui continue à jouer
vous ne pouvez pas me donner en deux
mots une définition du mot chance dans
le mythe françoise sagan puisqu'il est
il y a il ya donc le jeu il ya aussi la
vitesse et s'adonner à des chapitres 2
avec mon meilleur souvenir
ce ne sont pas des mémoires ce ne sont
pas des souvenirs c'est donc le dernier
sacre alors la vitesse je crois que vous
l'avez éprouvée dans votre chair à
préparer dès maintenant battu par
exemple on a joué un excellent moteur
dans ma vie un seul touché du bois qui
boit et
il ya longtemps et l'empêchant est un
jour je ne vais pas vite retrouvé garé à
60 à l'heure donc lancé mais c'est pas
de chance c'est toujours comme ça la
chanson je chante aussi parce que donné
la manière générale non c'était un
accident ce pas beaucoup
c'était une voiture de sport anglais sur
le thème aston martin décapotable ont
donné la mort décapotable et qui était
un peu lourde pour moi et puis kg
sur le gravier partie de ses partisans
il faut aussi qu est-ce qui vous grise
dans la vitesse c'est ce que déjà la
vitesse la vitesse est grisante par mm
oui je suis paresseux comme les jeunes
qui n'ont même pas évitons peuvent pas
comprendre le plaisir réalité faisant
siffler l'impression d'aller justement
ou ralentir par christine vitesse de les
arbres là le vent j'ai pas l'impression
très particulière est dans le sac en bas
bleus puisque vous êtes comme ça mais
d'hab le wiki 20 sa gang qui joue ou
sagan qui conduit vite c'est toujours un
peu la même chose
vous avez envie de vous prouver quoi
vous existez de machines retrouver jean
mai dernier je prends du poids j'ai
envie d'aller vite si vous voulez jouer
et j'ai envie d'être utile ont emmené
avec eux mêmes raisons vous écrivez
parce que comme vous lisez je vais lui
ou moi aussi je peux écrire la chance et
se mesurer à un a pas de pot et puis
conduire c'est se mesurer à la vie et la
mort ont passé commande curieuse vous
écris que vous existez vous même
pourquoi vous voulez ou systématiquement
vous prouver à ce qui est des gens pour
prouver aux autres ce qui est des gens
qui ont le goût de l'excellent fête arc
ou l'excellent définissez - parce que
c'est que l'excès pour mieux lexis tda
passé ces six années on corollaire de la
démesure
c'est un don
delicious exemple théâtre vous avez
plongé dans le théâtre avec succès
d'ailleurs
ou peut-être à cause de ça donne deux
interprètes j'en sais rien vous avez des
rapports bizarre avec le théâtre avec
votre expérience théâtrale
non pas du tout quelques pièces déjà des
succès j'ai eu des fours et puis voilà
et puis c'est un c'est un métier
extrêmement amusant et très agréable on
est plusieurs à le faire ensemble on
travaille en ce sens est en très bonne
équipe et c'est très reposant qu'on
travaille seul en général deux
puisqu'ils vont se trouver une équipe
pour travailler c'est au façon plus ou
moins que le roman moi je veux dire avec
mon meilleur souvenir
chabot avait des rapports tendus après
tout j'ai des rapports très agréable
c'est plus
en fait c'est ma vie facile et graphique
une prime mais des distances de
d'alternative de règles on va d'un mur à
l'autre en bondissant comme une balle
écoutez tout tombe dans le théâtre qui
coin impressionnant que j'organise une
liste liberté pouvant atteindre de faire
ce qu'on veut c'est beaucoup plus
impressionnant quand vous êtes c'est
facile vous avez vous éprouvé de la
difficulté écrit alan ball tour ici on
vous pièces et veronica difficulté ne
pas partir à vous lire ceux qui vous ont
lu depuis 30 ans c'est le premier jet
c'est le premier jet et le dernier ges
et il n'ya pas revenir sur la couleur
littéraire de ce que vous avez pas parce
que je suis ce que je suis venu on m'a
même plusieurs fois par semaine sa
précision la nature et ou qui peut
parfois vous avez parlé de ça les
pandémies les textes mérité deux fois
puis une autre et d'écrire une fois 7
mai lors vous m'avez confié autre jour
que vous n'arriviez pas vous redire sauf
parfois dans un avion comme sagan qui se
trouvaient à bord mais comment avant
même que le texte imprimé et 10 t elle à
l'officialisation du nid vous arrivez à
vous relire à votre propre juge et un
juge suffisamment critique pour dire non
évidemment ce sera une ligne s'est barré
donc la facilité c'est beaucoup
travaillent avec ceux qui travaillent
longtemps que nous le pensons
[Musique]